[Music]
now that the Terminator franchise has
been run into the ground and the Alien
franchise is on life support under the
finger the predator franchise will be
dug up from its grave dust it off and
have its face taunt in the predator did
you love the razor focused intensity of
the first and only good one well too bad
because this is a film about a team of
outcasts being hunted by an alien and a
predator rebelling against his own
people to save the earth and an autistic
boys unlikely gifts and one soldier's
quest to clear his name and a biologist
unraveling the mystery of predator human
evolution all at the same time in this
sloppy mess barely held together by
dialogue written by Shane Black
character and predator one he called me
do you know what he calls me so huh
beat the Looney's outcast soldier is
stripped of their ranks and all but one
character trait there's Thomas Jane
playing a man with movie Tourette's
Keegan stop doing your mama jokes how do
you circumcised a homeless man kick your
mom in the chin if your mom's vagina
were a video game it be rated E for
Everyone
the guy from moonlight mumbling threw a
cigarette theon greyjoy in search of a
reason to be in the movie
and the bad guy from Logan in a star
turn as a generic soldier with a very
elastic butthole they'll team up with
Olivia Munn a biologist who's combat
training comes out of nowhere because
apparently her intro scene had a real
predator in it and they'll all fight the
evil sterling K Brown who's here to kick
ass and chew bubblegum and he's all out
of he's all out he's up he's okay I
guess he's just here to chew gum and die
the predator is back to save us all so
this is his gift to humankind or not
it's unclear and this time the galaxy's
greatest hunter must face its most
dangerous opponent since dodge expansion
of the boar the dreads sensory receptors
for franchise purposes remember how I
told you how they take people's spines
right I think they're attempting
hybridization hey guys
alien hunts badasses is all we need
three word pitch done so if you want
desperate battles genuinely shocking
carnage and immortal one-liners rewatch
the original yeah stick around because
the only thing here being stalked killed
and kept as a trophy is your time you
are one ugly mother
starring GI Shaw Chuy young Sheldon
x-wing at Aloysius Missouri Western
State University dr. tough lady girl PhD
you versus the predator she told you not
to worry about stupor shredder Durotan
this is dumb and that thing where dogs
look like their owner
audience vs. predator Hulk
alien the thing I am legend the fly
ghostbusters
this movie why does every single nerd
franchise have evil dogs in it
can a monster get an evil turtle or
something my carpet matches my drapes
Peter Parker here to pick up a passport
please
I have the hubba-hubba man yummy yummy I
like hamburgers in my tummy
my hamster is in the gym